بينما تسيطر حاله الترقب بشان العمليه
العسكريه التركيه في الشمال السوري تستمر
المساعد دبلوماسيه الروسيه على امل التوسل
الى ارضيه اتفاق ترضي كلا من تركيا
والنظام السوري وما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه قالت الخارجيه الروسيه ان
العمليه البليه التي تخطط لها انقره سابقه
لاوانها ويمكن ان تؤدي الى مزيد من تصعيد
الموقف وتحفز المشاعر الانفصاليه وتفاقم
المواجهه المسلحه لكن موسكو رغم ذلك تتفهم
بواعث القلق الامني لدى انقره
هذا موقف يطالب الاتراك ضمنيا بمزيد من
التريث وتلك رغبه الروسيه معلنه تستهدف ان
عاش قنوات الاتصال بين انقره والنظام
السوري لايجاد مخرج يضمن تامين الجدار
الجنوبي للحدود التركيه ويحول دون توغل
بري تركيا ذكر ذلك بوضوح قبل اسبوع وزير
الخارجيه روسي سيرجيو بروف فقد قالينا
بلاده مهتمه باستئناف الحوار بين تركيا
وسوريا على اساس اتفاقنا الموقع عام
1998 وان المتطلبات الاساسيه نضجت للمضي
قدما في هذا الحوار في اتفاق اذنه يحق
لتركيا ملاحقه منتصفهم بالارهابيين في
الداخل السوري حتى عمق خمسه كيلومترات
واتخاذ التدابير الامنيه اللازمه اذا تعرض
امنها للخطر يريد الروس في هذه المره
قياده حوار بين تركيا والنظام السوري من
اجل العوده الى هذا الاتفاق او تعديله بما
يبدد المخاوف الامنيه تركيا من وجود
الوحدات الكرديه على حدودها الجنوبيه يريد
الروز ايضا ان تحفز مساعدهم قياده ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه على القبول بوضع
جديد يسمح بانتشار قوات النظام السوري في
مناطقهم لتطمئن انقره وتعدل عن التوغل
البري لكن قائد تلك القوات مظلوم عبدي ما
زال يعلق اماله على دور امريكي يحول دون
عمليه بريه تركيه دون ان يضطر للتنازل عن
مناطق الاداره الذاتيه لما تعرف بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه موقف يضع المساعي
الروسيه امام تحدي كبير لكن موسكو تعول
على توافقاتها ومصالحها مع انقره في ملفات
ساخنه عده لعل ابرزها تصدير الغاز لانجاح
تلك المساعي حرست لذلك الخارجيه الروسيه
على تاكيد وجود اتصالات وثيقه بين هيئتي
الاركان العامه واجهزه الاستخبارات في
البلدين ورغم تفاهم المخاوف الامنيه
لانقره فان منطلق موسكو كما قالت خارجيتها
هو الحاجه الى التقيد الصارم بمبادئ وحده
الاراضي السوريه واستقلالها